On behalf of the great state of Illinois, "Crossroads of the Nation", "Land of Lincoln",...
...let me express my deepest gratitude for the privilege of addressing this convention.
Tonight is a particular honor for me because, let's face it,...
...my presence on this stage is pretty unlikely.
My father was a foreign student, born and raised in a small village in Kenya.
He grew up herding goats, went to school in a tin roof shack.
His father, my grandfather, was a cook, a domestic servant to the British.
But my grandfather had larger dreams for his son.
Through hard work and perseverance,...
...my father got a scholarship to study in a magical place, America,...
...that's shown as a beacon of freedom and opportunity to so many who had come before him.
While studying here, my father met my mother.
She was born in a town on the other side of the world, in Kansas.
Her father worked on oil rigs and farms through most of the Depression.
The day after Pearl Harbor, my grandfather signed up for duty,...
...joined Patton's army, marched across Europe.
Back home, my grandmother raised a baby and went to work on a bomber assembly line.
After the war, they studied on the GI Bill, bought a house through FHA and later moved west,...
...all the way to Hawaii, in search of opportunity.